[Music]
for the rest
though this cult is in fact an act
its meaning yet lies mostly in devotion
what belongs to devotion is not
objectively produced
just as the result in the enjoyment of
the feast is itself
robbed of its outer existence
the cult therefore goes further and
replaces this defect in the first
instance
by giving its devotion an enduring
objective existence since the cult is
the common task
or the individual task for each and all
to do
which produces a dwelling and adornments
for the glory of the god
by so doing in part the objectivity of
the statue is transcendent for
by this dedication of his gifts and
labors the laborer inclines the god to
look favorably upon him
and contemplates himself as belonging to
the god
in part two this action is not the
individual labor of the artist
this particular aspect of it being
dissolved in universality
but it is not only the glory of the god
that is accomplished and the blessing of
his favor shed onto the laborer only
ideally and in
imagination the work has also a meaning
the reverse
of the first which was that of
alienating and glorifying
something alien the dwellings and
halls of the god are for the use of man
the treasures preserved therein are his
own in case of need
the honor and glory enjoyed by the god
in his adornment are the honor and glory
of the nation
great in soul and in artistic
achievement
at the festival people the p this people
adorns its own dwellings and garments
no less than the things of the god with
graceful decorations
in this way they receive from the
grateful god a return for their gifts
and proofs of his favor in which through
their work they become
united with him not as a hope and in a
future realization
but rather in witnessing to his glory
and in bringing him gifts the nation
has the immediate enjoyment of its own
wealth
and adornment
with paragraph 719
we are now closing out this
subsection the abstract work of art
in this second section
of the religion portion of the work
which means that we are as we're making
these transitions we're getting
closer and closer to
what it is that hegel tells us has been
driving
this entire dialectical process this
complex historical development
of consciousness the entire time
absolute knowing we still have to
now traverse two more
sections of this religion in the form of
art or religion as the work of art
portion the second portion of the
religion section we've
long since left natural religion behind
at least in the text if not necessarily
entirely in the gestalton the shapes the
forms that religion
is taking on because those are sublated
those are
transformed those are alpha hobna right
brought into this but we saw that
there's been
a really vital dimension
that got added or perhaps we could
actually say
two vital dimensions if i had to ask you
about this entire section
as a whole you would say well okay art
that's very
important but art specifically how
are we talking about the statue that
plays a role
in this paragraph and that plays a role
in
worship if we look at the history of
religions not just the statue
in a place like the temple or a shrine
but we could think of
idols of gods that is images of gods
created and kept in people's
homes or tense we could think of the
impersonation that takes place
in so many religions by masks which are
also
a form of the god yes that's that's
important right
so the handicraft the production the
attempt to
try to take spirit and not just
represent it but embody it
literally in foreshtelling in pictures
in representation that's an important
component
what else has been going on in this
section
language we saw that there's
important discussions earlier on
in this section about the language
of the hymn that allows the god to be
there in you might say a personal
narrative type of context
or format and there's also the
the language of the oracle and now
looking
ahead we're going to see at the very
end of this entire section that
there's another kind of use of language
that's going to turn out to be very
important
but what does that get folded
into in this section and what is the
subsection and what is the next
sub-section
going to continue to elaborate
in the section called the living work of
art
so you know there's there's
self-consciousness
there's enjoyment there's all of these
important
discussions the revelry of the god
trying to attain
some sort of free movement and
at the same time a
resting place that we can look at but
the word that's going to come up over
and over again
is the word that has been recurring
through really half of this subsection
and that is the cult what is the cult
we've seen in the previous paragraph
that
it is the locus of mediation
allowing human beings to
connect with each other and to connect
with the divine the god whatever the god
happens to be however the god is
pictured and to allow the god
a locust not just of worship
not just of being pictured as a passive
static entity
and not just a purely transactional
relationship
but for the god to exercise agency and
for there to be
genuine communion or if you prefer the
more
neoplatonic term participation
within the agency the
personality of the god all of this has
been
happening within the cult
and here we're going to see hegel
bringing us back to
something else that's going to run
through the next subsection you know
very explicitly the
nation the folk right
it's no longer just uh the
interesting religious community and how
individual worshipers or
even statue makers the artist right the
kunsler or the uh you know the craft
master anything like that is related to
the gut
it's now in terms of what we began with
the ethical zidlicus nation the folk
this is incredibly important so all that
said
and we'll do a little bit of reminder at
the end of this about where we are and
why it's important let's take a look now
at the actual text
so he says for the rest though this cult
is in fact
an act a han lung right
for the rest the rest of what's going on
it's meaning
he says yet lies mostly
in devotion so we're moving in this
paragraph
from the sacrifice of opperhung
in the previous paragraph the dynamic
economy we could say of giving
and giving up and all those
relations which turned out to have a
potentially
hypocritical problematic side where
somebody is
holding back and not really launching
into it we we see
in that i should have brought this up
last time the
dynamic of the noble and base
consciousness from
earlier in the spirit section do we not
at least an echoing of it so from
sacrifice to
devotion on docked he tells us that
the meaning the badoitong of the cult
is devotion on
sort of thinking looking upon being
there with the deity
and having a certain kind of comportment
it's not just like being there and being
like that
all right i'll give you five minutes
let's see what happens here
instead there's a reverence that's
supposed to be
taking place and now interestingly a
little bit of a digression here
when we have this kind of devotional
attitude it doesn't necessarily
need to be a religious object think for
uh you know certain christians the
devotion to the eucharist to the
bread and the wine that that's believed
to be
in some way and there's a lot of
different explanations of this so we
don't need to get bogged down in it
transformed into uh body and blood
recalling
an ancient narrative something that in
medieval times people spent a lot of
time
looking at the host more often than
actually consuming it so all of that
is a religious form and we could talk
about other things we could
do comparative religion and find all
sorts of other
interesting parallels there but think
about
since this is religion as a work of art
think about
how we treat the things that we consider
to be
artistic musical performances
do we approach those sometimes in
a spirit of devotion undocked
right sometimes we do sometimes it's
just background music
sometimes we're you know interested in
where
an album fits in in the top 40 or
something like that
sometimes we have the music on as a
pretext to do something
else let's get pumped up for the
football game right
but sometimes we're actually there to
like take in the spectacle
and see what's what and that's part of
what's going on here
in the cult so he says what belongs to
devotion
is not objectively produced
so that's that's going to be important
right this word objective gigensten leak
comes up here in a number of ways why
why is it important for things to be
objective or objectively produced in
this case
because it gives a stability to things
it gives them
a capacity to be
grasped by us but the object by itself
is
is not everything so he says
just as the result in the enjoyment of
the feast is itself
robbed of its outer existence what is he
referring to there well we're talking
about the feast that
was referenced in the previous paragraph
718 talking about the animal sacrificed
as the symbol of a god the fruits
consumed
are the living ceres and bacchus
themselves
so what what are we consuming
could be wine could be beer could be
whatever
right uh although i suppose you could
say that
you know bacchus serious if you're
making beer since
sirius is the uh or demeter is the
goddess of green
then you know maybe that would fall in
her province but
uh we have cereals things that make
bread
things that make the staff of life as
it's been called right
and we have things that make
intoxicating drinks or at least drinks
that we
can find refreshing and we consume those
and in consuming those
at the feast we are consuming the god
and we are also sharing
an animal with them we sacrifice
an animal we burn up certain parts if
we're doing you know traditional greek
sacrifice there's many other ways
of doing this and the smell you know
like homer says goes up to the heavens
and apollo or zeus or whoever
sniffs it in and they're very satisfied
or you know
if they were cheated to the good parts
maybe not satisfied
and then meanwhile the human beings not
just the priests but the congregation
the
participants feast upon the flesh
of the animal the rest of it so
this feast is consumed what happens
in devotion does devotion itself
become crystallized into an object
if it does maybe devotion is thereby
lost in the process right can you come
up with a
menu book for devotions you can
certainly find all sorts of devotional
prayers in
in nice books that you can carry around
you can you know again
if you're christian you can do the
liturgy of the hours you know very
common traditional thing pre-protestant
tradition that even some protestants do
as well and you can do it in a way that
is basically you mumbling through the
psalms and the
other prayers and the reading or you can
approach it in a way that goes beyond
the merely
objective right so he goes on and he
says
the cult goes further and replaces this
defect what defect the defect of being
not objectively produced being robbed of
its outer existence
in the first instance by giving its
devotion
an enduring objective existence now
notice how he's going to do this
it's not just in a book in a set of
pictures
in a wikipedia page in
some sort of thing that we can easily
pass
between ourselves in what we might call
an economy of theoretical knowledge
no the cult is the common task
the cult is something that has to be
done that is the meaning
here right a common task for who
for everybody it's a common task but
it's
also he says for the individual the
individual
task for each and all to do
so people have their individual tasks
and there's an entire we could say
hierarchy
and organization and and
moving from from a whole bunch of
different means to ends to other ends
within this people find their place
where they fit in and this isn't to say
that it's once and for
all it could be that you rise within
this or that there's initiations that
take place it could be
intergenerational as it very often
is and so he says what is this
individual
task for each and all to do what is it
about
produces a dwelling and adornments
for the glory of the god now this is
where we get to a different kind of
this is an objectivity that is bearing
upon another objectivity
so he says by doing so the objectivity
of the statue
is transcended transcended
hoban right afgha hobnes the gegen
steinle
the objectivity of the statue the statue
which is already a complex thing because
it's imbued with meaning
as the image the symbol the residence
of the divine within a temple or a
shrine or whatever else it is
and an entire set of comportments han
lungen
right that are part of the cult now
attains something additional and it's
not just so
when we think about adornments right so
think uh
for example of how statues
are of gods are treated
in uh hinduism to a certain extent in
in jainism although there's a lot of you
know
discussion about that and in in
other things as well so we'll take the
flowers
that are used to adorn statues right the
flowers have to be grown the flowers
have to be picked
they have an objective existence they
are woven into something
new they are placed over the statue
which then can be picked up
and moved somewhere else or remain in
place
people bring offerings and those
offerings are adornments we can find
many other examples
of statues being dressed in in different
ways
being treated in different ways i would
go so far as to say that
although hegel is going to talk about
christianity later on think of the
veneration of the cross
that takes place within various
liturgical christian denominations
and that could be an example of
adornment as well
including the particular comportment
kissing the cross
prostrating oneself before a statue all
of these
sorts of things are these adornments
just
so to speak window dressing or do they
matter in a certain way do they give a
new kind of
objectivity let that
you know mull that over a little bit let
it percolate
in your mind then think about dwelling
the vuonung
the dwelling of the god is the place
where the god
resides right and that's the temple
perhaps or the shrine but that itself
is subject to change to decoration
to having uh vestments
created you know to being
having works of art brought in all sorts
of other
possibilities in this way so he says
um by doing by so doing in part the
objectivity of the statue is transcended
why for by this dedication of his gifts
and labors
the laborer inclines the god to look
favorably
upon him there's this notion that i'm
going to get in good with a god by
making a beautiful
piece of cloth that'll be used for
something and that's not nothing
we may look at that as being naive but
if you already believe
that there is a relation that you have
with the god
and it is mediated in this place in this
time in these you know now long
traditional but always
somewhat innovative ways than these
gifts and labors that you're engaged in
r biten right that is a way for you to
connect with to do
something for the god we already saw in
the previous
paragraph that there can be a
realization that even what one
has to bring before the god is in a
certain sense something that is already
you know partially at least
a gift that the god has given oneself
right if you have a great
intellect that allows you to compose
hymns to the deity
god gave you that brain right or you
know at least something
that you can bring to bear if you're
bringing the food stuffs well that came
from
the gods in a certain way and so this is
not just
a you know as i put it before don't
worry a
purely transactional relationship
hegel says that this is a way in which
the laborer
contemplates himself as belonging to the
god
he also says this action is not the
individual
labor of the artist this particular
aspect of it being dissolved in
universality
how so well because you are one of
many doing these things you're not the
only person
decorating the worship space
if you are you're you're kind of
excluding the possibility of other
people being
involved with you and i think many of us
who have been involved in religious
congregations
know people like that who would love to
have the only relation possible
with the god and make themselves
basically the intermediary
by how they they arrange things choir
directors can be like that sometimes
let's put that aside for the moment so
he says
it's not only the glory of the god
that's accomplished and the blessing of
his favor
shed on the laborer only ideally and an
imagination
this is important right so hegel is
saying this is part of what's going on
right people are bringing
say flowers or people are bringing
candles even purchasing candles right
there
in the place they're going up to the
statue they're bringing their
hopes and dreams and requests and maybe
even haranguings of the god
to the worship space and that's
part of what is happening hegel's not
saying get
get rid of that that's no good what
whatsoever
but that's not all that's happening so
something else is is going on here he
says the work
also has a meaning the reverse of the
first which was that of
alienating and glorifying something
alien i brought up in the last paragraph
that what we're seeing here
is in part a resolution of the dynamic
that was worked out in great length
back in the self-consciousness section
with the unhappy consciousness
right that was you know to
make it very quick summary human being
the
the singular the individual the
unimportant
god is projected out there the divine as
the eternal the good
whatever is is you know important
victims right
whatever has essence or or reality
and then there's this attempt to bridge
the gap and the god doesn't respond in
this case the god
is able to respond in part because
of the mediation of the cult
that's being worked out here
here we take a really interesting turn
that prefigures
where we're ultimately going with
religion with hegel
he says the dwellings and the halls of
the god
are for the use of man the treasures
preserved therein are his
own in case of need
temples played a very important role
religious institutions
still do continue to play this role not
least because
in the scriptures of the great world
religions we see
injunctions to say hey the nice temple
area
if you got to give refuge to people that
and you know they're going to
muddy up the carpet in doing so that's
fine
that's you know doing the work of the
god
it's not supposed to be this pristine
you know sort of like back in the the
60s and 70s and 80s it was quite kind of
common
in you could say lower middle class
transition to middle class families to
lay down these plastic runners
and to keep the couches when they were
bought covered
with plastic so you don't have a real
dwelling place
a place for use and enjoyment instead
you've got this
weird almost museum-like thing that's
what religion
is not supposed to be and that's part of
what the cult
is bringing forward so the dwelling
dwelling in halls of the god
are for the use of human beings the
honor and glory enjoyed by the god and
his adornment are the honor and glory
now here we here we go
here i mentioned this important
transition of the individual
no not of the individual of the cult no
not even just of the cult of the nation
the folk the ethical people right the
zit leak is
uh folk so is it like
actually so he goes on and he says
the honor and glory of the nation great
in soul
and an artistic achievement and then he
brings up the festival
and this dwelling this this uh
adornment that this is for festivals
right just like the sacrifice was also
a component of festivals at this
festival the people adorns its own
dwellings and garments
no less than the things of the god with
graceful decorations
now what this presupposes is that there
isn't
you know uh terrible alienation going on
within society
so that people are like well listen
you've got your temple and your god and
you might
compel me to like sing hymns and come
forward and bring flowers or
you know dress the place up but he's not
he or she's not
really my god because you treat us like
crap
all the time you're not you're we're not
part of the
nation that would indeed be a problem
hegel doesn't consider
that here but that's certainly uh
something that could be
brought up so in this way they receive
he says from the grateful god a return
for their
gifts and proofs of his favor in which
through their work they become
united with him now notice what he says
here so they're united with the god this
is part of the function of the cult
you know mediation but not as a hope and
in a future realization rather in
witnessing to his glory and in bringing
him gifts the nation has the immediate
enjoyment of its own wealth and
adornment
so it's not just giving stuff up to the
priests giving stuff up to the god the
temples get super rich
there has to be a continual circulation
of giving and giving back and of
enjoyment of finding identity
and unity for oneself in the relation to
the god
mediated through the cult which is the
mediator
lurking in the background so
is this is this a depiction of all
religion no this is a depiction of what
hegel thinks
is best couple this with the previous
paragraph 718
the best that's being offered by certain
religions
at certain places and times and this is
a dialectical development
we're now ready to close out
this particular subsection the abstract
work of art
and to move on to the living work of art
and we could say that we're already
dealing with something that
is on the verge of being a living work
of
art in
a way actually the next two sub-sections
are both
dealing with living works of art
and so that's where we end this
particular subsection
you